the first case is the parole of Emile
Blonsky I love She-Hulk I miss this of
the Hulk you know I
try he is the Hulk it wasn't personal or
anything so he's a big man he's under
direct it's not personal government but
then you went oh no
the Rampage
because
who's they
um
yeah it's not I didn't do it but I know
who did not me it wasn't me I would
never do it I would never test too much
I would never pump this beautiful man
with this extra extra steroid but I know
who did I know who did and I can't wait
to get into it today because
welcome back to Stars you guys Betty us
enters the MCU again and it's Liv Tyler
is confirmed to make an appearance in
Captain America New World Order along
with her father Thunderbolt Ross now
played by Harrison Ford and Tim Blake
Nelson's the leader we've got a Hulk a
She-Hulk scar Abomination oh what's this
an Incredible Hulk staycation also the
run time for Guardians of the Galaxy 3
is much longer than the other Guardian
movies this one in particular needed to
be this long to really experience the
full Arc of every major guardian's
character this this was set by James
Gunn not by me is this the guardian's
farewell package or is it just James
guns we're going to talk about both of
these things today because it's
so much to take in and this is inside
Marvel new rock stars weekly Marvel
reaction show I'm Jessica Clemens here
with me today is Eric Boss and Mt hello
Jessica yeah this is this episode's
gonna be two hours and 29 minutes not an
ounce of bat on it not an ounce and I
not to be a butthole not to be a
butthole as soon as he was like no no
not an ounce of fat on this I was like I
better not see an ounce of fat then
that's right
then and I know yet the moment the
moment we see a bit of fat in the
opening act of the movie We're Just
Gonna Stand Up and Scream
side note when I was at everything
everywhere all at once a fight broke out
during the rock scene and I was like I
thought it was
The Rock scene is so quiet and this guy
was like if you're gonna talk get up and
talk then and I was like oh my God I'm
crying right now and these two men oh my
God watch out for was it between the
Rock and Zachary Leva
she's better than the movie how is that
a rock and I'm the rock there could only
be one Jesus be sure to check out
nerdriot.shop where you can always grab
the latest and greatest new rockstars
gear right now you can check out our new
line of merch inspired by the
Mandalorian season three support the
channel and check out our great merch
options over at nerdride.shop you both
are always wearing great merch you're
wearing the Super Mario Brothers new
rock stars merch it's so cute
our Deep dive shirts
today is Throw Some D's on it
Throw Some D's on there that's the motto
for the Deep dive we should try to remix
it but I think they'll come for us I
forgot who sings that song and don't
forget to subscribe again to our newest
Channel The Deep Eric just dropped this
deep dive on Tim Burton's the Batman
arguably arguably depends on the person
the best Batman
depends on the person the best Batman in
letterbox it was the highest ranked like
the Batman and I was like oh it's very
interesting I don't think they think
it's the best Tim Burton Batman I love
the movie but I think Batman Returns is
it better I think it's I think a lot of
letterboxes come into like nostalgia in
which one felt for a lot of people and
of that time that was a big Cinema
cinephile time so people were just like
this is the best one either way
Eric just dropped his Deep dive on Tim
burns the Batman and how it changed
superhero films forever as you know it
is the number one subscribe to the Deep
dive so you don't miss out on that and
let's get into our big discussion today
about Betty Ross returning to the MCU
what does this mean MCU with Betty
Ross's return yes there's a lot of
questions around this but a lot of
theories I think more theories than
there are questions so Betty Ross has
literally now entered the chat now
videos appeared in 2008's Incredible
Hulk played by Liv Tyler she's also
Thunderbolt Ross's daughter a scientist
a professor the love interest to Edward
Norton's Hulk eventually in the comics
she does become the Red She-Hulk at the
hands of Modoc in the leader what we
know in the MCU right now is that in
Captain America New World Order they
casted not just her Tim Blake Nelson as
Samuel Stearns aka the leader who was
also featured in The 2008's Incredible
Hulk Carl lumbly as Isaiah Bradley Danny
Ramirez as Joaquin Torres our new Falcon
and newcomer Shira Haas as Sabra we
can't also forget of course Anthony
Mackey as Captain America but what does
this mean for the hulks altogether
because we could have five potential
Hulk blood related catastrophes in the
MCU now if they turn Thunderbolt Ross
and Betty Ross both into hulks like they
do in the comics I just want to hear
from you guys what Betty Ross could mean
to the MCU and what we're looking
forward to with her return yeah I never
thought they'd get live Tyler back in
here they had uh the the form of Liv
Tyler from um an episode of what if
remember
um so it seems like there's there's
still intent on bringing her back
because they completely changed the look
from uh Ed Norton to Ruffalo there but
they kept the look of Liv Tyler right um
but yeah I think we uh it's just
interesting how they're still afraid to
make a Hulk movie maybe the the rights
might be tied in at Universal we don't
really know though because Universal
hasn't really tried to develop a Hulk
movie in like forever so uh yeah I think
we're going to see uh Captain America
new world order that has the backdrop of
a Hulk family movie uh that's kind of
what it seems to be the case uh if
you're gonna have Harrison Ford as
Thaddeus Ross and his daughter
um now the set photos that have come out
look like it's at a like a funeral
setting where where mackie's arm is in a
sling do we think this could be the
funeral of uh the former president
ritzen from Secret Invasion Dermot
Mulroney or Dylan mcdibly uh you know
one of the most confusing actors in
Hollywood
um yeah do we think he might die and
then that's like the funeral they're at
and then that could Ascend to Thaddeus
Ross like vice president Thaddeus Ross
in the position of the presidency that's
what I'm kind of wondering about the
police I think president Richton has to
be the president because there was not
only the little uh it wasn't a spoiler I
wouldn't say his boy it was a piece of a
piece of a newspaper that had him in it
and I think in New World Order and then
we have that little Stinger of it uh the
ticker of it and wakanda forever so I
think it's leading to like President
Ritz something has to happen president
either that he's a scroll or that he's
dead and I want it to be that he's a
scroll because it's like I don't
would would it make for I guess would it
make for a good storytelling if
president Ritz and not a scroll does die
and then the next person in line is
Thunderbolt Ross and then we just have
to figure out
where's Thunderbolt Ross has been since
we last saw him would that make for uh
too much too little I think having the
president be a scroll would be like the
ultimate
um fear tactic for like people like Val
to use
um to make the people scared for the
Scrolls in the MCU and I think that um
yeah I think having the president having
the Scrolls infiltrate the presidency
would freak people out yeah and like it
would probably bolster uh president
um Red Hulk who's just like super
anti-alien super just super like
basically like we can't have anybody
coming down to our uh planet we have to
build a wall around the planet basically
um this is probably gonna be a lot of
parallels to that but uh yeah I feel
like it's probably going to be a
scenario where um uh the president gets
replaced by a scroll I think that'd be
really fun yeah I think you're right Mt
I think secret Invasion we do see a shot
of dermit Mulroney in uh presidential
um as like an SUV like part of the the
motorcade and it gets hit it gets like
hit by a missile or something like that
so I wonder if the real president Ritz
in gets killed but that's just kept
under wraps and then they replace him
with like you know the the Kevin Klein
movie Dave they replace him with a
puppet version version of him who is a
squirrel pretending to be him right so
that conspiracy gets exposed by Thaddeus
Ross who leads kind of the military
industrial complex and he's like you can
trust me get off my plate I need to find
my wife and then so we he gets thrust
into power through some kind of like
constitutional crisis or something like
that maybe there's some kind of coup but
he's able to seize control the White
House maybe there's an election to
justify it uh and then he gets to become
president that way but like the fact
that Liv Tyler is coming back too you
know it puts her in a position where
she's gonna have to temper her old man I
don't know if they're gonna make Liv
Tyler or Hulk too because you know you
know are they really gonna put uh the
budget behind hulking out live Tyler as
well I think at that point might become
just too much of a Hulk movie the thing
what I would like if I had to choose
between Thunderbolt Ross turning into a
Hulk or Liv Tyler I'd probably choose
Liv Tyler and that's only because
um this is a really stupid example but I
was watching an interview with Matt
Stone and Parker from uh uh from ages
ago the creators of South Park where
they said if you say and then if you're
writing a script and you keep saying and
then and then you're gonna be trapped in
a hole but if you say therefore this
happens that's that's when you don't
find yourself in that hole and I think
turning uh Thunderbolt Ross into the
Hulk is a more and then and then and
then and then this happens but I think
turning Liv Tyler into the Hulk is like
okay so therefore Thaddeus Ross is gonna
be like my daughter's a Hulk like hulks
have ruined my life and this is his
reaction is becoming the president and
being like we need to stop all of these
things from happening I like that
storyline in the comics where
Thunderbolt Ross turns himself into a
Hulk because he hates the Hulk so much
like that's he's like I'm gonna turn
myself because I'm that's the only way I
can defeat a Hulk so I think him slowly
going into madness because his daughter
that justification that motive is really
good to change I just also maybe she
gets turned into a red Hulk by dying
first uh I know I love when people die
in these movies but giving him like
that's his daughter I think is what
lifts him up to become president no
those are all really really good points
but I think that Liv Tyler as inclusion
in a new world order is super super
important considering um Liv Tyler's um
status as a scientist in the MCU because
like we would not have the Incredible
Hulk of the way he is if it wasn't for
Liv Tyler's work on
um radiation in the human body it
specifically Bruce Banner's body being
able to absorb massive amounts of gamma
radiation without dying um it's her
science she she made a um an antidote or
a serum that allows Bruce to be able to
accept the radiation so I think that
having her in this movie especially with
a um a maniac who was obsessed with
improving Humanity like the leader I
think that he wants to probably use her
to try to like figure out that perfect
formula that you
to get um you know the super soldier
serum legacy two people or two himself
maybe he wants to use it to himself to
further enhance his brain but I
definitely feel like
um it's it's gonna be Liv Tyler sorry
develop Tyler Benny Ross is silent
science that um
um the leader probably wants to uh get
get at to uh help synthesize
um this new superpowers within people
because he's obsessed with just
improving people and like getting rid of
sickness and that's his hell will Mo so
um I feel like it's live Tyler's gonna
be blue Tyler's character is going to be
a big
um help for him I think the leader I
it's so interesting okay so those are
two things I realize I just bridged uh I
just bridged the hell out of Betty Ross
so take I take back everything I said do
not kill her do not turn her into a Red
She-Hulk to make him go higher
um switch it up make him Red Hulk either
way so and then secondly I still want to
believe that the leader because it's
like we don't know where he was this
entire time and um Emile Blonsky knocked
him out he knows that like he hit his
head on the ground the blood went into
his head so I think he still has that
like yeah this is the guy that broke
into my lap forced me to give him the
Hulk blood turned him into a wild man
and then I got turned by being just
under his control so I want to believe
that the leader has just been sitting
there the entire time watching Emile
blonde ski turn watching him turn into
like from a heel to a good guy and just
being like this guy sucks and so I think
Emil blonski is kind of
a I are not available
[Music]
or being used by Val who knows but yeah
it's just him being a watcher rather
than an active member doesn't make him a
little bit of a I think the I
think with the title like New World
Order I think the the goal of this
fourth Captain America film will be to
expose the history of government
operations kind of the Cloak and Dagger
operations the you know kind of the
secret projects and that includes uh
weapons plus I mean that like I think
exposing the history of the Captain
America Super Soldier program that's
what the first Hulk movie was they've
always shared that DNA the the first
whole film to phase one Hulk movie The
Face one Captain America movie and I
think this movie could kind of Bring It
Back Together uh with a character like
Thaddeus Ross the fact that Isaiah
Bradley is going to be in this as well
just kind of tells you that those uh
those storylines from the Falcon the
Winter Soldier of like what the United
States government was doing the latter
half of the 20 20th century uh how Hydra
corrupted that operation and how um
really the one with all the secrets to
all of that history is Thaddeus Ross
um I think he's gonna be an interesting
character just mine for information I
mean there was that detail remember in
the Falcon Winter Soldier credit
sequence how it says like refer all
information referring to this file to
secretary Ross secretary Thaddeus Ross
and we all thought that is Ross is going
to show up in fact when his children he
didn't
um I think all that stuff is going to
show back up in this show uh we'll see
if the the TMF theories end up coming
true uh but I think the more likely
reach Theory I'm gonna go with for New
World Order is something like Wolverine
I think uh at least establishing that
history
um uh I think that's gonna be that's why
Ross is so important that's what I'm
thinking about with Sabra because we
don't have we've never been introduced
to her so was she someone that changed
because of the soldiers super soldier
serum or what they have already and
that's why I think it's more heard than
it I think it's gonna be an X-Men but I
also I'm like there's so much happening
in a new world order that I'm kind of
I'm not scared but I'm just like okay if
we're gonna start going over like the X
Gene if we're gonna be going through the
Hulk blood again if we're going through
the super soldier serum again and then
we have Falcon and then we have uh Sabra
and then we have the hulks what is is
the main focus just the science part of
this or is it the government part of
this or I think the main focus is the
plan like I think like
uh put that on a thumbnail no but I mean
like the government's plan for super
soldiers and for superheroes and
superheroes that they can control I
think the plan is going to be like the
mutant plan but like uh falling short of
mutants things like super soldiers like
hulks you know like you know like
wolverines we might not get Wolverine
introduced yet but I think they're gonna
show us like hey the government had like
uh it was like the boys like we're gonna
see the boys side of the MCU they were
trying to control
yeah and the military interests that I
like geopolitical interests that oh do
you think they'll get into the disease
that was in uh Falcon in the Winter
Soldier that's what I was gonna say yeah
because we got asked all a lot about
like that whole uh uh Donia madani
storyline from and then that there might
have been a pandemic where related
subplot and now to be clear the director
and the head writer I almost included
this in in my recent investigation but
the director and the head writer both
insist that whatever was removed from
the Falcon Winter Soldier was not a
virus subplot but it was something that
like just like didn't work and it was
something within the flag Smashers in
the character
um of Donya madani their matriarch who
was just randomly killed off despite
being cast as Veronica Falcone who's
like a very talented big name actress
um so I think it was something to do
where she was kind of there there Isaiah
Bradley like she was part of this
history of the super soldier program and
then for whatever reason like this stuff
just didn't come together or maybe the
scenes just didn't really make sense
with other things they were working on
and they had to trim it down uh but I
think they might use that the whole
history of super soldier programs around
the world and in different uh
governments
um could be established I like that I
like that yeah I feel like the common
thread in New World Order is
specifically um with um the leader being
the main antagonist is just super human
people
um in general people that are extra
human so like your super soldiers fall
into that your hulks your mutants um
potentially fall under that as well so I
think that new world order could be that
Catalyst that pushes the enhanced human
the overall enhanced human narrative
forward
um in in all three of those respects
um it's sort of just to prepare us for
the mutant Saga um furthermore so yeah
perfect I love this and there's more
theories on its way when we get back
into inside Marvel but first we'd like
to take a moment to thank our sponsors
that help bring inside Marvel to you
when you're waiting around for your
character to get brought back into the
MCU you're going to want to get a good
night's sleep and for years we hear a
new rock stars have trusted our sleep to
Helix Helix makes premium mattresses and
bedding that are customized to fit your
needs and conveniently shipped right to
your door which Helix mattress is right
for you don't worry about it Helix made
a sleep quiz that matches your unique
body type and sleep preference to the
perfect mattress for you based on your
different sleep positions and firmness
preferences they have something for
everyone's unique taste and if you sleep
with a partner you can take the Sleep
quiz together and find something that's
perfect compromised for the both of you
I love my Helix mattress again I told
you I'm a big bodied woman I'm a thick
lady I'm a She-Hulk and my bed is
perfectly fit for my size and I sleep
alone actually I sleep with my cat so
it's perfect for both of us the best
part about all of this is that Helix
delivers your mattress right to your
door with free shipping in the U.S plus
Helix has a 100 night sleep trial so you
get more than three months to make sure
that you love it or you'll get a full
refund Helix mattress has a 10 year
warranty and they even offer financing
options and flexible payment plans so a
great night's sleep is never too far
away I love my Helix mattress and I
think you would too if you're looking
for a new bed check out Helix you can
click the link below or go to
helixsleep.com inside Marvel to get 20
off your Helix mattress plus two free
pillows that's helixsleep.com inside
Marvel alright guys our next question
for today is what is the full Arc for
Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 3. great
question because this movie's coming oh
okay you guys yes okay wait I know that
empty I'm ready for it I'm ready to hear
what you have to say about this so James
Gunn I'm just gonna I'm gonna summarize
what he's been talking about lately so
James Gunn left no room for fat he his
words not mine and Guardians of the
Galaxy vol 3 explaining a series of
tweets that though this is the longest
of the Guardians of Galaxy movies
running at nearly two and a half hours
which isn't as long as like it is as
long as end game right and it was like
three hours in game was three hours and
two minutes I think end game I mean two
and a half for a movie I'm always like
is too long but this is better than or
is not as long as the other ones to me I
don't think it's that long either way it
doesn't matter to me I bring my catheter
yeah I'm fine you're disgusting but this
one this in particular needed to be this
long to really experience the full Arc
of every major guardian's character as
he said he fully said in the suite and I
promise not as second is wasted there's
no fat it was necessary to experience
the full Arc for every major guardian's
character not only for this film but for
the trilogy or should I say Trilogy plus
and when he's saying Trilogy plus he's
talking about his movies the Guardians
one two and three and the plus is the
holiday special Infinity war and end
game but he also mentioned in an
interview with total film recently the
most important thing for me was rocket
story and then following that everybody
else rocket is the secret protagonist of
the Guardians of the Galaxy and has
always been the center of it for me and
this is really fulfilling that the
reason I came back and decided to do
this movie was because I really felt
like Rocket's story needed to be told
and it was left hanging after volume two
so that's the most important thing the
end has always been like the looming
phrase for all the Guardians of Galaxy
movies and the synopsis even mentions
that uh if they're not successful in
this Mission it could possibly lead to
the end of their story altogether and I
feel like using the word Arc implies
that it's an end point so what is the
full Arc what is it what is it I get I
get that like um rocket is the point is
your is your point you're like we need
to go over his but I guess what is the
full Arc to the Guardians franchise to
his storyline and to the characters well
I I think um overall especially for
Rocket I think the overall Arc for
Rocket is is finding his family but also
dealing with his past dealing with your
past and following your family that's
that's the whole thing with guardians
and then we saw that with guardians of
galaxy Vol 2 with Peter and him um
confronting his dad and like him finally
getting to meet his dad and him
realizing this dad was an and
overcoming that and him being happy with
the family that he got but Rocket's
story was still very much being told
throughout that trilogy and it wasn't
finished with Guardians 2 like James
said
um because like we we we
I just totally glitched out because
remember with yondu
um in rocket that whole um relationship
and Guardians 2 was super special
because yondu saw
um himself in rocket and how damaged he
was and how his past kept him from
moving forward and developing
um a real family
um and he because he they both thought
that they were
lovable like they were like they were
just so irredeemable and like at the end
of gardens Guardians 2 Peter says no
like it's fine we'll always forgive you
and I think that's really important and
so now that um they they're all a family
rocket still has to resolve his past
with the high evolutionary much like
Peter resolved his um issues with his
dad so that's sort of that main thing
it's like all right you can't really
move forward with your new family if
you're still hung up on your old family
type of deal and the rest of them had
like families that kind of got like Drax
is kind of actually Drex I don't know
technically I guess it came to a
conclusion but nebula's definitely did
and then mantis we kind of figure out
that she's the sister the Star-Lord so
it's like it feels like everyone kind of
got a story fully maybe well not really
because like we we still have mantis
who's still trying to find her place in
the world
um you know nebula lost her sister and
like that was the only family that she
had left after you know Thanos got
snapped away so there's still stuff left
there there's Drax in his um you know
how to where does Drax Go From Here
Thanos is gone so like what's his
um ending um so like all those little
stories need to be wrapped up especially
also uh Adam Warlock and that little
teaser at the end of Guardians 2. that's
a big um uh story about fathers
um coming up there
um but yeah it should be really great I
love Guardians it's a family story it's
all about dads and and finding new
family yeah I think there is um kind of
an inherent theme to James Gunn's work
as a as a whole but especially in these
guardians of galaxy films of Brokenness
accepting one's scars and flaws as part
of your identity and being able to find
that as a common link with a found
family as opposed to the family you were
born into that was especially the case
of volume two right uh Peter had to
choose between the his the family he
chose the family who chose him and the
family that you know didn't necessarily
choose him he was just kind of born into
there might be a more of a kind of a
darker more of a mature discussion
that's explored in volume three of does
my existence do more harm to the
universe then I love that
um because you have to think of it in
terms of Rocket like they all of these
characters were kind of born out of
these tragic circumstances like Peter
Quill only exists because ego horrified
finally oh wooed Meredith quill and then
left her with a brain tumor
um mantis is also the spawn of ego
um a nebula at this point is part
machine part uh the carbon creature but
like they they've all used to be
children of Thanos and committed these
war crimes uh and rocket rocket kind of
has this like I compared to that that
really sad Meowth episode of the Pokemon
Animated Series yeah right
or there was like he there was this
other cat that he fell in love with yes
sir because she was obsessed with people
he's like oh I'll turn myself into a
person who walks on two legs and I'll
talk and then like she's like oh you're
a freak
and then that's why he's so sad and he
joins Team Rocket to try to kill Ash and
Pikachu it's like so sad and I feel like
there's something there with rocket like
a rocket may feel like we are uh by
being the product of the high
evolutionary I allowed The evolutionary
to profit off of myself and I gave
himself a template of blueprint to use
to create all these other creatures who
are have these buried mental health
issues you know so like yeah I don't
know if that's like a a ponderance on
self-destruction and on existence as a
whole but like I think the Guardians of
the Galaxy may be dealing with the fact
that the Galaxy doesn't want them to
guard them anymore so they're kind of
feeling this sense of redundancy or are
we actually helping right now or are we
creating more problems that's so sad
it's so sad but I like I feel like even
when he's going to James going off to DC
like that was like the big tweet that he
said about uh Superman Legacy that he
was just like yeah it's the day my dad
passed away and it's a lot of like these
are like our families and remembering
but also dealing with the most saddest
things in the world maybe I hate I hate
saying it but it's also true uh from
sadness usually comes joy and maybe
that's like what the Guardians 3 is
gonna be is like it's gonna be succumb
to sadness but it's going to be like a
breath of fresh air for them
um God damn well
any happy words before I sign off on
this no like if there is if there's
anything that James Gunn knows how to do
it's read a really great story about
dads Because James Gunner really loved
his dad
um a lot and like you could you could
see that in all of his um movies and
like I love that he's going to be doing
Superman Legacy specifically for this
reason because Superman is a massive
story about dads
um and like I think the Legacy part of
Superman Legacy is going to be about him
being uh like his him being the son of
two two fathers so um yeah it's gonna be
fun it's gonna be great can't wait and
uh to put a positive spin on this like
uh I think what's what I'm excited for
this is we might actually get a finite
ending
um to to Something in the MCU and I
think we often associate Indians with
death but endings are just
Transformations right uh and I think you
know if you think of uh return to the
king where Frodo goes to the gray Havens
and he leaves because I think he views
like he's like this Middle Earth is not
for me anymore I need to move on I need
to find a new adventure and that's how
stories can end it's just characters
just leave each other and this era of
their life is over but they are going to
find a greater happiness and peace by
doing something else that is not like so
mired in Conflict right that when we
watch these protagonists in movies we're
often seeing the most traumatic phases
of their lives so just to let that
character be happy and live their best
life just take them out of these these
War scenarios please
yes James will do a great send-off you
guys that's it for this episode of
inside Marvel remember to subscribe to
the Deep dive Channel at Deep dive NR
follow me at Lulu underscore Clemons
follow Eric at EA boss and follow Mt and
master attainment subscribe to inside
Marvel wherever you get your podcast and
we'll see you guys later bye bye bye
[Music]
thank you